Let's take a moment to review slip. Using
the slip setting of your machine, needles
in B or working position will not knit.
This is used for the slip stitch technique
and knitting in the round with the ribber.
It's also referred to as free pass.
Let's say you need to move your carriage
from one side of the bed to the other
without knitting or dropping
stitches. Keep all needles in B.
Set your carriage to slip and you can
safely pass it across the knitting.
On some knitting machines, you can set
the cam to slip, left, right or both.
With the Taitexma 160, there is
only one part lever. Engaging
that part lever means needles in working
or B position will slip
in both directions.
To knit I-cord or anytime you want
to alternate slipping and knitting
you need to move the lever.
With the part lever engaged, I'm pushing
my carriage right and the needles slip.
You can see that the stitches didn't knit
and the yarn is just carried across.
Move the lever to plain and it will
cancel the slip and knit
the stitches when I knit back.
We create I-cord by alternating slip and
knit with the passing of the carriage.
This can get really tedious on this
machine if you're flipping
that lever back and forth.
But there is an easier way.
One more time.
With the part lever engaged,
needles in B will slip.
But needles in D or E will knit.
So to knit I-cord,
put three or four needles into working or
B position, pass the carriage
left and the needles will slip.
Pull out the needles to D or E position,
pass the carriage and then stitches will
knit and they're all
returned to B position.
With the needles in B pass
that carriage left and the needles slip.
Pull the needles out and the stitches will
knit and they'll automatically
be put back into B position.
This is so much easier.
No need to flip that part lever
back and forth.
Here's an example of free pass.
My carriage is set to slip,
the cam lever is set to part.
When I pull out needles, they will
knit even though part is engaged.
With the needles remaining in B position,
I can free pass back and the
stitches won't knit or drop.